former tampa bay buccaneers wild
receiver antonio brown is speaking with
us in his first network tv interview
since that dramatic moment when he
removed his jersey and himself from the
middle of the game and there's some
breaking news brown tells cbs news he's
now considering legal action against the
team we traveled to brown's home state
in florida for a very honest
conversation about what really happened
that day
now even if somebody says
you know what antonio i feel you like i
would have did the same thing you can't
talk to me like that i'm a grown man
yeah you tell me to get the f out here
that's exactly what i'm gonna do exactly
but as a teammate though yeah if i'm
playing with the tampa bay buccaneers
yeah and off in the distance i see
something going on but i still got a
game to focus on
and i see you leave the field
i got to keep it real with you i'll need
you too
yeah
i would be mad at you i would be
frustrated because you know we call each
other family we're brothers and if i
look over in the midst of the game and i
see you taking off your pads your jersey
getting the crowd hype as you're jogging
off the field yeah i'm gonna be upset
with you what about us what about this
family what about this goal
yeah and i respect that and that's what
that's what good teams have you know i
didn't really have a
you know a deep connection with my
brothers like you say in the midst of
that i want to get back to um the
narrative that
a b is losing his mind so i thought that
was dismissive to what was going on
whether somebody say he's wrong for what
he did and how he left the field
or if they say he's right he's calling
somebody crazy saying he's losing his
mind
or immediately pointing to cte yeah um
that that just i think it minimizes
what actually happened on the sideline
but i have a question for you and you
can answer this
however you want to if you want to yeah
have you ever been diagnosed with a
mental health condition and do you
believe that has been a factor in any of
these public incidents i never had a
mental health diagnosis like
you know what i mean like i never had an
issue a problem i don't take pills i
just got a high iq
i'm an advocate yeah for therapy
uh
do you have a therapist in your life i
mean i try to do the nfl but i don't
really got time to consult with random
people i don't know about my mental
space or how i look at things most of
the people from different forms of the
world like i'm from the pit most of the
people we talked to they from the palace
so how your lenses look at life is not
how moz is
i mean that's some honesty right there
i'm from the pit i'm not from the palace
yeah he was very honest and and so was i
i told antonio brown
you were wrong
taking off your jersey gesturing the
crowd and quitting on your team
i felt like you were out of pocket
unacceptable you seem to acknowledge
that and he was very receptive of it but
he also said he didn't feel it connected
it sounded to me like he said i didn't
feel a connection to that particular
team is that how you read it that is how
i read it he he basically was saying
that this wasn't a family like everybody
thought it was from the outside looking
in it seemed like i was quitting on my
brothers he said but some of these guys
aren't my brothers now you can see the
entire interview tomorrow with
intelligent very good that was a tease
and and i'll tell you this he's going to
share some details that shed a light on
why he was released and it might change
your perspective not on antonio brown
right but just maybe on the situation
okay